qui se souvient aujourd'hui de 7 de
l'afghanistan de city 6 pages se dire
c'est important aujourd'hui quinze ans
après de dire voilà ce qui se passe en
afghanistan quand même c'est un pays où
on a été impliqué pendant plus de dix
ans on a mis énormément d'argent et on
continue d'en mettre
l'afghanistan reste un terrain
extrêmement difficile compliqué avec des
zones contrôlées par les talibans en
2001 il y avait un consensus malgré tout
peu on allait sortir les afghans de
l'art de laurent cabannes demande du
moyen-âge et c'est donc et c'était après
le 11-septembre et c'était donc une
réponse logique pour plusieurs d'entre
nous qui suivent ion le débat puis
plusieurs parlementaires canadiens
je me souviens quand je suis arrivée là
j'ai fait des reportages sur les petites
filles qui sont retournés à l'école sur
les femmes qu'on découvrait que tout à
coup pouvait sortir dans la rue sans
avoir peur de se faire battre parce
qu'on l'a pas ce qu une cheville
dépasser ou parce que mais je le cheveu
sortait de leur voile enfin il y avait
tout ça faut se souvenir de 50 m en 2001
on est vraiment dans une autre époque
il faut comprendre aussi que c'est dans
un contexte au canada a dit non quelques
années auparavant vous en irak est à
l'irak
donc le canada avait comme une dette
envers les américains sont dit nous on
va en faire la vienne et sap en est
capable les gens s'attendaient à ce que
le canada prenne une province beaucoup
plus facile compte tenu nos moyens
publiquement qu'on avait en religion
était étonné c'est ptet les espagnols
l'hexagone les français quand il y avait
quand même des régions qui était moins
dangereuse pour les forces occidentales
les militaires canadiens n'étaient pas
bien équipés pour cette mission il
aurait fallu avoir des hélicoptères rf
liés à être peut-être plus nombreux les
soldats sur le terrain tu l'as vu comme
moi patrie c'est à dire que eux ils
croyaient en cette mission là il était
sûr qu'il faisait une différence
il voulait être là il voulait bien faire
il faisait les choses un peu
différemment les américains ils
n'avaient pas la même approche très dur
que les américains pouvaient avoir eu au
contraire il était il fallait gagner les
coeurs et les esprits alors on parlait
avec lui avec les afghans il y avait
beaucoup de choses que les canadiens ont
bien fait beaucoup m'ont donné l'image
d'une couverture quand on déplace la
couverture à droite pour pacifier un
endroit x mais à gauche les talibans
reviennent on se re des places à gauche
à droite les talibans reviennent
beaucoup d'afghans 10 est pas tellement
qu'on les aime pas on vous a mis sur le
dos mais restait en tous cas si vous
êtes pour être ici rester le temps qu'il
faudra pour pacifier leurs droits
moi je pense que sur les femmes il ya eu
des progrès qui ont été faits c'est vrai
qu'il ya plus il ya encore de la
violence envers les femmes mais quand
même
elles sont maintenant plus au courant de
leurs droits il ya eu un peu
d'alphabétisation et une ouverture qui
s'est fait quand même là dessus des
stations de télévision il ya du
journalisme qui se fait mais il reste
encore beaucoup à faire je prends et sur
le travail là n'auraient pas pu se faire
sans la présence de ces militaires là
parce que ça n'a effectivement sur un
que les critiques mais imaginez si
personne n'avait misé aucun soldat
n'avait mis les pieds en afghanistan
après 2011